goofing off in class you might just get
a pass turns out class clowns may be the
smartest kids around
a recent study aren't they all asked
children to come up with captions for
cartoons humor experts meaning no one
from the colbert show judge the best
ones and discovered that the funniest
lines were written by the smartest kids
proving you could be smart and funny
which i always knew but who could have
predicted i'd also be good looking
emily for more let's go to a clown for
comment
sure i was known as a bit of a cut up
back at yale but has all this clowning
helped lead to my success well
let's just say when i get out of a tiny
car with 30 of my friends now that car
is a bmw
cat you were a funny looking child yes i
was yeah i sent in a picture earlier
today would even use it on the show i
was a heinous looking child no you
weren't no listen
literally yes i was emily don't lie to
my face
there we go you tell me i'm not an ugly
kid and i will tell you you're a liar
but it's great because then i had to
have a sense of humor or else i would
have never survived
yes it is survival what do you think
emily i'm telling you guys she was an
adorable child i've seen your photos you
were adorable always a weed whacker who
took my hair
um but what i thought was funny about
this study is that it specifically said
that it was it didn't hold water for
adults
i'm sorry for looking at you when i said
that but basically so the intelligence
funny corollary only goes for kids but
it did take place in turkey so it might
have been a cultural equation in turkey
yes who does studies in turkey about
comedy
these guys i'm like picturing erdogan
being like i gotta craft this joke i'm
so smart how am i gonna make the timing
hit and then i'm like and then he's
gonna kill somebody yeah and then he
gets eight guys out there to beat the
crap out of you on a sidewalk hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else